are
sick of this pandemic
all of us want to spend time with
friends and family but an event council
is better than a life cancelled
it's better to cancel now and celebrate
later
than to celebrate now and grieve later
who director general tedros gabriele
said they're issuing a stark warning
end-of-year festivities can drive
infections and lead to more deaths he
also said there's now clear evidence
that omicron is more contagious than any
other version of the virus so far
that's why the world health organization
is calling on people to consider the
risk they may be taking
well here in germany the government is
introducing new restrictions intended to
curb the spread of omicron german
chancellor olaf schultz announced the
measures after an online meeting with
leaders of the country's federal states
germany's center for disease control had
been calling for maximum contact
restrictions to be introduced
immediately but the planned measures
will uh will take effect after christmas
here is the chancellor
estrada we're now threatened by the
fifth wave
omicron is advancing in britain denmark
and the us
this variant differs significantly from
previous ones
according to the experts it's more
aggressive
and has characteristics which allow it
to get past the protection offered by
vaccines
even those with double vaccinations and
those who've recovered face a high risk
of infection
more on this with a doctor and a
politician dr johannes wagner is a
pediatrician and an mp for the green
party which is part of germany's
governing coalition welcome to dw doctor
um will these new restrictions delay the
omicron wave
good evening yes well we hope so um and
we will do everything which is needed
and on the other hand side we also do
have to prepare a general lockdown so in
case we need one next year this can be
implemented very very fast but for now
with this measures we are going to
we are hoping to see a further declining
of the numbers but and actually the
numbers are still declining but we have
heard um just a few seconds ago that
omicron is on the rise so that's why the
combination of those measures and
planning a general lockdown or preparing
a general lockdown in case we need one
next year is the best um yeah best
option right now
why not uh general lockdown
now we heard that the robert [ __ ]
institute is calling for for one why
ignore the experts and pander to to
people and say all right well we'll just
keep it open for christmas
well because the the federal states did
not
use every possibility they had until now
to reduce the the contacts we first need
to yeah
reduce context within the the current um
framework and then see if
really the the omicron
numbers are rising as fast as in other
countries
the most important thing of course is to
have a vaccination campaign
still over the over the holidays as well
and only with a high number of
vaccinated people we can at
some point end the pandemic that's why
in our opinion it was okay for now to
to booster the vaccination campaign to
really strengthen it and and to
make the people clear this is very
important to get vaccinated and very
very fast to get the booster and also
those restrictions which are
actually very very tight restrictions
but we don't need a general lockdown
right now with the numbers um declining
but we have to be prepared okay from
march uh german medical workers in
hospitals and nursing homes will be
required to be vaccinated against covid
and should this be extended to the
general public
in my opinion yes we have to close the
gap of people who are not vaccinated
because this is the only measure to get
out of this um we are always again
coming waves of
pandemic waves of coronaviruses and uh
of course
we also have to have in mind that this
global pandemia is only over if it's
over globally we have to also rise
numbers of vaccinated people in other
parts of the world we have to support
other countries in the world to to get
their population vaccinated but also in
germany we need higher numbers of people
vaccinated and as far right now we did
not have succeeded with the with the
options we have so in my opinion yes we
need a monetary vaccination next year
and how would that work would it would
you
say you have to get vaccinated or we
will find you or we will put you in jail
what would you do
no we will not put people in jail but of
course a fine could have possible could
be a possible measure
if people are not vaccinated or to
have certain
enter restrictions in place for the
whole year for example like the
restrictions to only get into certain
stores if you are vaccinated or
recovered those are possible
measures to to implement monetary
vaccination but of course we have to
discuss this um
voluntary vaccination campaign um in the
in the bundestag and there we have to
exactly define what kind of measures
could be what kind of restrictions could
be possible understood thank you so much
for joining us dr johannes wagner and
lawmaker for the green party in the
german parliament
thank you
meanwhile u.s president joe biden has
announced new measures to tackle the
pandemic a major part of that will be
the purchase of 500 million rapid tests
they'll be delivered to americans for
free when they order through a new
website it means they won't have to pay
for the test themselves and then hope
their health insurer reimburses them the
president also plans to deploy an
additional thousand troops with medical
skills to help overstretched hospitals
here's some of what he had to say a
little earlier if you're not fully
vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and if you get sick you're likely to
spread it to others including friends
and family and the unvaccinated have a
significantly higher risk of ending up
in a hospital
or even dying
almost everyone who has died from covet
19 in the past many months
has been unvaccinated
all these people who have not been
vaccinated
you have an obligation to yourselves
to your family and quite frankly i know
i get criticized for this to your
country
get vaccinated now it's free
it's
convenient i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly gotta believe it's your
patriotic duty
patriotic duty let's explore that with
dr amish adalja who's a senior scholar
at johns hopkins center for health
security he specializes in infectious
diseases and pandemic policy welcome to
the day doctor um more vaccines 500
million free rapid covert tests but no
lock down is that
enough i do think it's enough when when
it comes to lockdowns you have to
remember that they are very limited in
their usefulness because they are very
hard to comply with and they have
negative cascading impacts that will
have repercussions on many parts of
society so we want to remember that this
isn't march of 2020 this is december of
2021 and we have met much better
precision guided tools to be able to
limit the impact of omicron and it's
particularly on our hospitals than we
did back then so i don't think that we
need lockdowns i think what we need to
do is more testing more vaccinations
antivirals monoclonal antibodies i think
that's how we move forward in this new
phase
and this latest um cluster if i can put
it that way there's this latest cluster
of of uh of new measures from
governments around the world this is
being driven by omicron
how is this new variant changing this
pandemic and the response necessary
well we always knew that this virus was
going to mutate to become able to get
around the immunity from prior infection
the immunity from
vaccines and that's what omicron
represents
and i think now it's time that we start
to focus on what really matters when it
comes to coven 19 and that's preventing
severe disease hospitalization and death
that cases are always going to be there
because this is not a virus that can be
eradicated or eliminated our goal is to
tame it to make it much more manageable
and i think omicron has accelerated that
process because we're seeing so many
breakthrough infections occurring this
is something we're all going to get we
have to learn how to risk calculate and
learn how to differentiate between mild
breakthrough cases and what really
counts severe disease hospitalization
and death so i keep hearing people
saying that we're just going to have to
get used to living with covet as you've
done there so
what does that look like in future is
that just more is that just more mask
wearing and more boosters and more
social distancing
from here to to to death
what it means is that we now have
another respiratory virus that we're
going to have to contend with every year
just like we contend with flu and rsv
and the whole host of viruses that cause
cold-like syndromes but what will happen
with cova-19 is it will become tamer as
we get more of the population immune as
we get more tools like antivirals such
as the one pfizer is developing or
monoclonal antibodies and more rapid
tests and we get better at making smart
choices and risk calculating but there
are going to be some people that
continue to wear masks for some period
of time others may not but it's going to
be something we have to deal with in a
way that
i think most people haven't really come
to grips with and i think if you look at
the very beginnings of this virus with a
with an efficient efficient spread
through the respiratory route an animal
host it was never going to be eliminated
or eradicated and i think the world was
done a disservice by not by people not
being honest about this becoming an
endemic virus that was not going to be
eradicated but it's interesting that you
talk about this being endemic which i
think lots of us can can see how that's
going to be the case but you you use the
word tamed there so it's it's going to
be with us it's going to be around us
but you seem to imply it's not going to
be as deadly whereas
it's been the opposite it's become
deadlier and and faster so you see it
peaking and then dipping
right and what's going to make it tamer
is probably nothing that the virus does
we're going to make it tamer we're going
to make it tamer by getting vaccinated
we're going to make it tamer by having
antivirals we make we're going to make
it tamer by having monoclonal antibodies
medical science is going to what be what
what tames the virus it's not the virus
itself that gets tamed it's our ability
to cope with it improves to such a
degree that it's not something that can
kill at the rate that it could and
president biden's message was get
vaccinated get vaccinated get vaccinated
according to the cdc 61 of americans of
all ages have been vaccinated is it
possible this far into a pandemic
to to identify those who are still
reluctant to get vaccinated do they fall
into any particular social ethnic or
political groups
well what we find is unfortunately our
pandemic response has been very tribal
and people in one tribe particularly
have not really been
forthcoming with get wanting to get
vaccinated so if you can if you look in
the in the country these are pockets of
places unfortunately it's it's males it
tends to be republicans that's the
problem that we see we see and i think
it's because politics has been so
infused into this pandemic response
but hopefully you know uh former
president trump just a couple of days
ago talked about himself getting a
booster vaccine and advocated for the
vaccine hopefully that starts to move
the needle into people's arms especially
his supporters who are the main holdouts
but it is very very difficult now it's
become something where people are very
dug in and it's hard to see an easy
solution other than talking to people on
a one-on-one basis and trying to
persuade them that the vaccine is the
right thing for them to do because it
will benefit their lives personally
fascinating thank you so much for for
joining us and sharing your expertise dr
dr amisha adalja from johns hopkins
center for health security
thank you
well in the united states omicron is now
the dominant variant by far according to
accounting for three quarters of all
infections just a week ago that figure
was uh one in eight in new york virus
cases are surging just ahead of the
holiday season gatherings
five four
three
two one
happy new year
this is just a test new year's eve in
times square has not come early but the
omicron wave has hit the u.s sooner than
many experts expected
nearby new yorkers line up to get tested
with christmas just days away and cases
surging many are worried
it definitely feels like that first wave
of the pandemic with that anxiety all
these long lines around the city people
getting tested
exams are getting cancelled for people
in grad school like myself so it kind of
feels like that early part of the
pandemic where we didn't really know
what was happening i think we've all
been affected as a new yorker we're
trying to take every single precaution
that we can
got double vac boosted regular testing i
am planning to travel for the holidays
but depending on the result of this test
i'll probably stay put in new york
america's top pandemic advisor anthony
fauci though had a hopeful message for
those worried about the holidays you can
go the extra mile
and get tested before you have a family
gathering or group
get tested the day before or the day of
getting together
but vaccinated and boosted people one of
the family members of vaccinated should
feel very comfortable
in getting together and enjoying a
holiday meal or a holiday get together
despite the worsening situation in times
square some people were still in a
festive mood but this might be the last
time new yorkers see these lights in
person the mayor still hasn't decided if
new year's celebrations here will go
ahead
you